Who in here likes soccer?
Me, me!
All right, Leo.
Yeah!
You have to work really hard to be good at teaching.
And the best teachers are the teachers who are always learners.
It's been so eye-opening to see how many are struggling.
Meet four teachers...
When I went in, I wanted to be in the most urban school.
...who have 180 days...
A lot of them don't know anyone who's graduated from highschool.
...to make a 180-degree change.
Their well-being and their future really depend on how well I prepare them for the next level.
From Academy Award winner Davis Guggenheim and Participant Media.
I will always be a learner and a teacher.
It's not a job,...
I think sometimes we forget what it's like to be the student.
...it's a mission.
In terms of the ideal teacher, I don't know if I will ever get there 100 percent,...
...but I'm just gonna keep on going for it.
Teach.